- OK, Gronkowski family.
I have to start off by saying I have never
seen a group of men that look so much alike.
You all look exactly alike.
It's like you’re brothers or something.
This is like a big family reunion.
So I'm excited to talk to you guys about
the YouTube channel. Before we get to that,
Rob, obviously the question right now that everybody
is asking is just like, how close is this new Gronk
to this “vintage” Gronk? What would you say?
- Oh, wow.
- Vintage.
- Well—
Wow.
Vintage.
That is crazy.
That's, you know, that's a special word. You know, Vintage Gronk.
That sounds like I'm coming out of a movie.
But, you know, I'm just out there working hard,
just getting back to that football terminology,
getting my football legs back underneath me,
cuz that's such a thing too.
You gotta, you gotta actually compete versus other
players in order to get the football legs back.
Now, when I was facing my brothers in basketball and Home Run Derby
and a lot of other events, it got me ready a little bit.
And then when I stepped on the field, it was a little bit
different, a little bit faster. But I'm just getting back at
it, feeling good. You know, just trying to get better every day.
And, you know, I got a long camp ahead of me, so there's a
lot of football to be played and a lot of room for improvement
for sure.
- Now, you guys, tell me: What can we expect from the YouTube channel?
I'm very excited for this new content.
- Well, first off, how I got ready for the
season this year is because I stayed competing.
It wasn't necessarily football, but I was doing
everything else, from getting checked in a limo bus,
you know, to get me prepared for hits up the middle
all the way to shooting basketball,
competing versus each other, getting paint balls shot
at me from my brother while I was on a Jet Ski.
So just put it that way.
Imagine paint
balls, you know, the pain of paint balls as you're
flying across on a Jet Ski and getting hit with it.
Got me ready for training camp.
And we got many other activities too.
Glenn, Chris, Gord,
what else did we do?
- And you got those—
- Yeah.
- For a big hit.
- Yeah,
what about those squats you were doing when you were,
you were pulling creatures
out of the middle of the ocean.
- Oh, yeah, that too.
We were pulling some crazy creatures out of the middle of the ocean.
Can't tell you what type of creatures they were yet.
We were on Blacktip. Blacktip. You know Josh, the Blacktip guy
out there who's been catching these massive, like,
flounders and stuff? Well, we caught a lot of good
stuff out there that it was definitely a workout.
Like,
bringing it up and you held your core tight
the whole time, so it got you stronger there.
So, that's what was so cool about doing all the shooting is that
it was always activities that kept us balanced, you know?
You know, if we didn't work out that day, we were basically
working out doing the activity, doing the competition.
So that's how we try to incorporate it so we can knock a few
things out at one time, but also make it, you know, entertaining and fun.
- I would love to hear how beer pong, that
competition, can get you ready for some football.
- That's some hand-eye coordination right there.
- Yes.
- And mindset.
- That was actually water pong for Rob.
Everyone else was, you know, having a little bit more fun.
You gotta drain it in the cup. You gotta drop it in the bucket.
We all know what's going on with that.
So, you know, Rob had to get ready for the season.
So, you know, we gave him an excuse to just have
some fun and drink some water and get hydrated.
- I was playing water pong for real.
I think that's why I, you know, I placed pretty high.
I didn't, you know, I'm not gonna say if I won or not, which
I didn't, but I came close because I had water
and everyone else was getting tipsy and I was just laughing
cuz I knew they couldn't see the cups properly and I could.
- So he was cheating, you guys! No, is there anything for
the channel that one of you really wants to do that
the other ones don’t?
- Yeah, so we actually did a tightroping
competition as well, which I thought was pretty cool.
And I wanted to keep going higher and higher
on the tightrope, and everyone else
was getting too scared to try it out.
So that's something maybe next time, we
weren't very good at it,
but I don't—
- Why are you telling all of our secrets, bro?
- But, I mean, we got some other cool stuff, competing
against each other in every single one, but some fun
competitions, like the beer pong and the cooking, Home Run Derby.
We’re singing, playing some guitars and stuff like that.
Bringing in some influencers and other
celebs to have some fun with us as well.
So it's gonna be a really fun channel for sure.
- For sure.
So you guys are clearly, like, an incredibly fun family.
When I tweet search you, there's, like, some people that
are like, “Oh my gosh, I would love to be Gronk’s brother.”
- So I'm gonna tell you guys—
- Thank you.
- Yes, you're welcome.
I'm gonna tell you guys
five other famous families, and you guys are gonna
rank which ones you would like to be a part of.
You can collectively decide it. You're gonna talk
it out amongst yourselves as I give you the names,
OK?
Will Smith and Jada Pinkett Smith’s family. The Currys.
The Hemsworths. The Kardashians. The Carters.
You can either go from, like—
- The Carters being the Backstreet Boy Carter?
- No.
- Or, or—
- Beyonce and Jay Z.
- Beyonce, yeah.
- Ohhh.
- Wow.
- I was gonna say, Rob would wanna be part of the
other Carters, being a Backstreet Boy.
- The Backstreet Boys!
- So which one really sticks out?
Like, that's your easy No. 1.
- No. 1, I’d probably go with Will Smith.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, me too
actually.
- I feel like he’s just well-rounded, you know?
That's just my pick.
I don't know about you, bros, if you guys feel
the same way, but that's just how I feel.
- Yeah,
I love Will Smith's movies too.
- We’ll let
Dan actually participate
since he hasn't participated.
- Yeah, I would say, I would say the Currys. They're good people.
We did an interview with them, my dad and I, with the parents,
and they got some good basketball players that
we could hang out with in the backyard
and slam dunk on them, you know?
- I think they'd be really fun to play three in
the bucket with, so.
- Yeah.
- I actually thought opposite—
- That’s a
basketball game we play at our house.
- I don't wanna play three in the bucket with them.
- Yeah, that's true.
- They would make three on everyone.
- All right, so the final game that I play, and
I do this with everybody that I interview, is the game Heads Up!
These are the categories you can choose from:
hip-hop, football, basketball, TV, movies.
- I think we should all have to do movies
just because football would be too easy.
- Three, two, one! Uh, it's where the guy locks
everyone into a basement, and there's a series, like
1 through 8, and he makes them do crazy things.
- Oh, “Saw.”
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Girl movie with pompoms and they, uh—
- “Bring It On.”
- Yes!
- Wow.
- Oh, not a unicorn, but…
- What?!
- Pass. I don't know how to—pass on that one.
- It's where you're trapped inside a
square and you're freaking out, uh—pass.
I’ve never even heard of this movie. Pass.
- Me neither.
- Wow. Pass again.
- Um, it's also a song out in California.
I think it's a Tupac song, and they did the movie on it.
- Oh, “Straight”—not “Straight Outta Compton.”
- Yeah.
- That's not Tupac, but OK!
- Whatever.
- Um, this is not an Avengers movie.
There's another group of guys.
- Um, “Fantastic Four.”
No, it's, um, like baseball, basketball and then—
- “The Dream Team”?
- Pass, pass, pass.
- Oh! Um, wow.
Man, how do you even describe these—pass.
- Oh, my God.
- That one was easy.
- Oh, uh, about a tornado.
- “Twister.”
- Yeah!
- Abraham.
- “Lincoln.”
- Yes.
Correct.
Um, not Manchester United, but—
- Manchester City?
- No, no. Pass, pass.
Never seen it.
OK.
- Not daddy, but—
- Mommy! “Mommie Dearest.”
- Uh, no. Father…”Mother!”
- I think—did Gronk win?
- Oh, yeah.
- Congrats, Gronk!
- This is semi-Jack, and this is Semi-Diesel!
- I must say, after sitting here and getting to know
each of you, I'm so excited to watch your videos.
This was so much fun, and congrats on the launch of your channel.
And thanks for joining!